thank you
ASAP Rocky ringing in Sun rizza's first
birthday
growing big beautiful happy baby yep the
rapper shared these sweet pics and
videos over the weekend to celebrate the
Milestone giving a rare look at home
life with his and Rihanna's little guy
hey man
the never before seen snaps include lots
of candid moments from this shot of
Rizza and dad to this mirror selfie with
Mama Riri he's amazing he's a happy baby
in the post ASAP references Wu-Tang Clan
the rap group The couple likely Drew
inspo from when it came to naming their
son which is cool you know according to
the Daily Mail which obtained a copy of
the official birth certificate Rhian
asap's baby's full name is Rizza
ethelston Mayers
what's the name and looks like Rihanna's
hinted at the name too repping lots of
Risa merch since the baby's arrival what
is the best part about motherhood right
now Rihanna oh my God the morning's just
like seeing his morning face yeah and
you know like seeing a baby with like
little bags and waking up and they're
just like startled they're trying to
figure out where they at it's the cutest
it's my favorite part of the day oh my
God the mornings that's like I I cherish
that I'm in love I'm obsessed and I
don't even feel guilty about it it's all
an exciting Journey so far I'm just
taking it as it comes the singer's now
getting ready for a new addition to her
household she announced the pregnancy
news during her iconic Super Bowl
halftime performance in February
right
[Applause]
it's a second pregnancy how are they
different from the first one
um just everything all of my
no Cravings tons of nausea everything's
different but I'm enjoying it
[Music]